uh Adriana from Sopranos started in only
fans at 51 years old oh my goodness
which to me is hilarious
um
like I don't I don't even know who this
is Adriana
I think your name is um
she starts in about 15 years too late
oh this chick yeah she was on um I think
she played uh Joey's brother on that
sitcom TV show Joey right
in the show after friends she played his
his uh his cousin or sister or whatever
I guess like kind of seriously ironic
thing is that
I don't know if you remember a few years
ago when only fans decided they would
stop they would stop hosting like
illicit content and then they backtrack
at the last minute because everyone's
like oh no you're gonna lose a bunch of
money and this is kind of what they had
in mind 51 year old women posting
pictures of themselves
20 or 30 years too late
yeah I mean uh
I mean she's got the link here in her
Instagram which is where they would
normally put it but I guess you know
times are tough for her in the acting
world and you know one does this one
does is that her kid in the second photo
I always love it when you see them
posting kids and such oh yeah yeah so
yeah so good Lord
High School yeah imagine you're in high
school and they're like yeah well you
know your mom does only fans so she's a
hoe but uh so her character in The
Sopranos was kind of like a trashy you
know a trashy hole essentially you know
Mobsters girlfriend and she's come
pretty close to that now with this yeah
definitely checked off she embodied that
role
anyway so if you guys want to sign up
for uh Dre Di Matteo's only fans and see
a mom of two uh taking off her stuff
then have out of guys
this is what I've been waiting for
convert's been waiting
who's telling her in her ear that Hey
listen there's money on the table you
have to do that even if it's only like
even if she makes like say five ten
thousand dollars a month or something
like that is it worth your dignity and
like the the harassment that your kids
are going to get for doing that
it doesn't show how many how many
subscribers they've got on only plans so
just click the link over here to see it
it says eight posts 11
300 likes on her post so that so that
suggests to me that there's a lot of
people that follow her it doesn't say
the subscribers but that suggests with
eleven thousand three hundred likes you
know that these Sims are giving this 51
year old mommy of two money
um anyway like I said that you know
there's there's no end to thirst it's uh
it is out there I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out